so twitch just had to go and make fall
guys competitive
they recently hosted a 500 000 twitch
rivals event where some of the biggest
streamers on the platform competed
but then xqc ruined everything he stream
sniped dr lupo
he pissed off shroud he confused the
[ __ ] out of tyler1 he got banned off
twitch for seven days
and he got banned from twitch rivals
events for six
[Music]
months
all right you know the deal subscribe to
the channel not only does it help us
figure out the stories that you want to
see
but guys we're on our way to 2 million
subscribers
so you know just scroll down and hit
that little button
if you do maybe i'll think about not
swearing so much in these videos
so back on november 2nd twitch announced
that at this year's
digital version of twitchcon aptly named
glitchcon
they'd be hosting a fall guys twitch
rivals tournament as one of four
different
showdown events twitch split up a bunch
of big name streamers like shroud dr
lupo tfu and xqc into four separate
teams
and it had them duck dip dive and dodge
their way to a cut of a five hundred
thousand dollar prize pool
tifu is currently in the middle of his
pre-game
snack there what do you do to get ready
for an intense tournament like this one
tifu
um nothing honestly
i don't care who won we're here to talk
about xqc
because well he just had to go and get
banned
again we'll get to the ban in just a
second but
first let's talk about what the hell he
did i'm gonna put you in emo early mode
this is a bad
[Music]
now that clip you just watched is a
little confusing so
let me break down what actually happened
basically
xqc stream sniped dr lupo so previously
xqc had been eliminated from the match
that he was competing in and because
it's xqc
he wasn't just content to sit around and
chill so
apparently he queued into a match with
dr lupo and shroud and held another
player back
which in turn caused dr lupo to get
eliminated from both the match and the
tournament
and if you didn't know a big part of
fall guys is [ __ ] with people which
includes holding them back so they can't
move on to the next
round let's get him let's get him though
now the reaction to xqc stream sniping
dr lupo came in three different ways
the first being from the streamers who
actually participated and out of
everyone you can imagine it was shroud
the king of com himself
who was ready to rip some heads off
people were talking about like why is
xcc have so many viewers and i'm like
because he's [ __ ] hilarious
and now he does that and all my respect
is quite literally gone
you know you seriously screwed up when
shroud has lost all respect for you
jesus but from there he was kind of in
shock and
started speculating about a potential
ban i'm in disbelief he literally just
made twitch history that has never
happened before
no big partner has ever done that he
quite literally just made twitch history
i don't even think he knows that he did
i don't even know i don't even think
twitch knows what they're gonna have
what they're gonna do i don't know if
they're gonna ban him for a week
banned for a month banned him for three
days i have no idea
and shroud basically called it because
xqc did get banned
and i swear we will talk about that ban
in just a second but
first watch this complete and utter [ __ ]
show involving
tifu xqc and tyler1 i'm sorry you can
win tyler
don't lose your excuse and you have to
stream
and hold my members down cause you're a
loser
was it tyler there's participation
awards for people like you okay yeah and
you didn't get
first second you're gonna get [ __ ]
last yo tyler shut the [ __ ] down
you scrawny [ __ ] right snap you
tweak look at me ride up little ass
honestly that is an all-time twitch
moment and probably one of the funniest
things i've ever seen now i mentioned
that there was three different waves of
reaction to xqc
stream sniping the first came from the
streamers involved and the second was
from social media people seem to be
pretty split between
it's fall guys who gives a [ __ ] and xqc
cheated and cheating is wrong and one of
the funniest moments to come from both
sides
is hassan just going in on the absurdity
of this controversy
it was actually one million dollars and
also
there were [ __ ] like children that
were rescued
from an indonesian nike factory that
were playing
and literally if they didn't win they
were going to go blind and actually see
[ __ ] stream snipe
and literally caused those indonesian
child
labor factory workers to go blind and
lose out on a million dollars now within
the social media response
we seem to have a bit of a conspiracy
theory going on here
see xqc fans think that the reason that
xqc stream sniped in the first place
was because dr lupo had someone stream
sniping for him
this dumb idea was kind of implied by
the man himself
oh and here we go here's the loop
climbing up fall mountain
i like how wait did you guys see that
um the sniper gave him the win
now as you might imagine dr lupo was a
little more measured in his response
one game where i got a crown it looked
like a guy doubled back for a second and
i passed him and i ran up and jumped and
so there's like
xqc viewers are saying that my stream
snipers gave me a crown when i should
have
shouldn't have gotten one but you like
you can't really tell and i obviously
have no co
like i have no control over that and the
third wave of reaction comes from twitch
and here is where [ __ ] truly gets wild
because on wednesday
a few days after the tournament twitch
released a statement
banning xqc from the platform for seven
days not only that he's banned from
competing in all twitch rivals
tournaments for a period of six
months plus he has to forfeit any prize
winnings from the event
and then on thursday a day after they
initially announced xqc's ban
twitch doubled down and handed temporary
bans to his teammates nightblue
mendo and grand pooh bear now tifu is
also banned from competing in twitch
rivals events plus he has to forfeit any
of his prize money but he's not banned
from streaming on the platform
tfu will forfeit prize winnings from the
glitchcon event for being aware of the
act with his teammates
and failing to inform the admins that
this was occurring end quote
people have done some pretty dumb [ __ ]
while streaming
and when twitch finally gives us a
reason for banning somebody
it's over a fall guys tournament now
twitch makes the argument that they're
trying to preserve competitive integrity
but let's be honest in this case what
[ __ ] competitive integrity
it's a bunch of jelly beans running
through an obstacle course
banning xqc from twitch rivals events
for six months i understand
he broke a bunch of rules that are
stated in your terms of service but
banning one of the biggest names in
streaming
off the platform again [ __ ] twitch is a
stern warning
not enough it's so funny watching this
play out because we
all know this ban is gonna have no
effect on xqc
whatsoever he's probably gonna come back
to insane viewership
and honestly is anyone surprised he did
this
xqc is the embodiment of chaos he's
turned getting banned on twitch
into a brand and him doing this brings
us to the kind of complicated nature of
when you're hosting tournaments
that put entertainment before serious
competition twitch decided to
invite what are essentially entertainers
to compete in a series of tournaments
with 500 000
on the line specifically because they're
entertaining
but then when xqc does what he always
does
create chaos and be entertaining on
stream which by the way twitch pays him
millions of dollars to do
he gets banned for it twitch tried to
have the best of both worlds here
and in this instance it backfired and in
a world where who does
and doesn't get banned is a constant
topic of conversation
where the messaging from twitch about
these bands is inconsistent at best
this this dumb controversy is what gets
a clean
and polished statement it took weeks of
streamers getting banned due to dmca
strikes
in order for twitch to put out this
muddled blog post the priorities here
definitely seem out of whack now after
twitch announced the ban
xqc quickly made a pretty funny
non-apology
and said that if twitch donated his
forfeited prize money to charity
he'd match the amount and eventually
tyler1 and shroud both weighed in on the
aftermath
and as you can imagine neither of them
was particularly impressed
i actually didn't think he was gonna get
banned a lot of people were saying it
was blown out of proportion
but i think it was the opposite i don't
think it was blown up enough
so i thought twitch was just gonna like
let it slide and they were gonna be like
oh [ __ ] nobody really cares
cool hey you see bed yep i know good
hope it's permanent what i always can
say to that loser
enjoy youtube is what i say the question
i was going to ask keith was would you
be pissed if this would happen
would have happened but then i was
thinking that i'd probably be the person
to [ __ ] do this
just considering uh how i often act
in um uh multiplayer games like uh it's
definitely true that
it's like definitely true that no matter
what game you're playing
you're more likely to try to [ __ ] with
your teammates than win
yeah that might have something to do
with how bad you are at video games but
i think it's both me being bad and i
just like sadistic side of me where it's
like i find it funny even though it's
not to anybody else but
you know the king of team killing
himself devin jones honestly i miss team
killing i haven't played any
counter-strike
you missed the thing that you miss about
the game
i just love to see their reactions as
they [ __ ] die to one of their own you
know
yes i am and eventually both shroud and
tyler1 chimed in on the aftermath
and as you can imagine then